check out this week's must-see movies  the latkes have resolved to exterminate  up underworld blood Wars is an  action-packed horror movie about warring  vampire clans well what did you hear  looking for someone haven't you ever  seen a mind like the one your daughter  has you have to see that she becomes  hidden figures tells the true story of  three brilliant women at NASA we can do  the work in the breathtaking fantasy  film a monster calls a boy embarks on a  life-changing journey of lost courage  and faith here's this week's fan tissa  patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting below see  you next time on weekend ticket  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]